the decorations may give it a very
festive feel but this isn't where we
expected Prince Philip to be so close to
Christmas or where he would want to be
24 hours after he went into hospital
there were no updates from the palace on
his treatment or condition we know the
Queen is carrying on with her festive
plans after traveling on a train to
Norfolk on Friday and this is why since
the 1980s
Sandringham has been the place where the
Windsors gather for Christmas the Queen
and the Duke playing host and leading
the family to church
Philip hasn't been at the service for
the past couple of years but still join
the celebrations behind the scenes it is
all about tradition and protocol and
things been done a certain way
even though Prince Philip possibly may
not be there but for the start of that I
very much think it will still carry on
as normal whether one of the other
members of the family may fill the room
wherever that may be that Prince Philip
and it takes as they're helping the
Queen host at Christmas it's possible
that she'll have support from other
members of the family for this but no I
don't think it will it will affect it
too much at all Prince Harry who sent
this message to one of the military
charities he supports won't lien Norfolk
this year the Duke and Duchess of Sussex
are taking a break with their son Archie
with the palace only just confirming
they're spending time in Canada the
country where she lived and where we
first saw the couple together in public
but there is precedent for not being
with the Queen at Christmas with Prince
William and Kate spending time with her
family in 2016 every year there is a
huge amount of attention around the
Queen and her family at Christmas
usually it's around Norfolk but for now
it's here in London as we still wait and
find out whether or not Prince Philip is
going to receive any visitors here at
the King Edward the seventh as he
continues to be treated for that
pre-existing medical condition the
palace have been keen to play down any
suggestions that this stay in hospital
is serious even though he is 98 years
old
now we just wait to see if he will be
well enough to join the Queen once again
for Christmas Day Rhiannon Mills Sky
News and the King Edward the seventh
Hospital